let's get started good evening everyone
i'm brian kilmeade and this is fox news
primetime
the unmistakable theme of yesterday's
inauguration you fell in the valley
because aside from
the calls for unity it was security
washington dc was boarded up locked down
and flooded with troops
there were 10 times as many national
guardsmen in washington d.c
as they're currently in afghanistan
right now the overwhelming security a
result of the january 6 attack on the
capital you know about that and thank
goodness there was no repeat of the
violence you're glad about that still
joe biden's address made it clear who
his top enemy is
in the battle for the american soul a
cry that can't be any more desperate
or any more clear and now a rise of
political extremism
white supremacy domestic terrorism
that we must confront and we will defeat
okay well everyone in the capital was
focused on the threat of violence
never panned out but there was chaos in
america you probably didn't hear about
thousands of miles away left this
violence once again exploded across the
west
in cities that are far too familiar with
this unrest have been watching this
channel
probably watching this channel only you
got in portland antifa thugs carrying
batons knives and
molotov cocktails attacking an ice
facility because it was an ice facility
smashing window at oregon's democratic
headquarters figure that out has joe
commented on that yet
i don't think so on the walls f biden
they sprayed that on the windows too i
guess elections don't have consequences
with these clowns
the scene not much better in seattle
where rioters damaged
an amazon store and the country's first
starbucks make sense of this
in denver they burned american flags in
front of the state capitol so
we're in joe biden's speech that he
condemned antifa
how hard is this violence is violence
why was everyone silent in the summer
why would they mum in the fall why are
they continuing to ignore this story in
the winter not us
we're going to break down exactly what
happened last night